et merci d'être avec nous quel rôle peut
et veut jouer l'union africaine dans
cette résolution du conflit libyen
quel rôle doit jouer l'union africaine
un ca a été rappelé tout à l'heure en
2011 l'union africaine et de nombreux
pays africains ont été mis de côté
il n'était pas pour cette intervention
en libye sur la personne de kadhafi qui
n'était pas un démocrate mais il voulait
plutôt tablé en tout cas travailler à
une transition politique
ils n'ont pas été écoutés et là encore
sur la résolution du conflit libyen un
pays qui est partagé en trois il ya une
bonne partie des pays africains et
notamment frontaliers qui vivent déjà la
crise s'aliène ya des raisons endogènes
locales mais aussi international
géopolitique payer à la libye ou en 2011
une bonne partie des armes qui étaient
en libye se sont disséminés dans les
pays frontaliers même si depuis
maintenant il y a entre guillemets
presque une autonomie des groupes
terroristes même si encore des liens
avec la libye donc l'union africaine
veut absolument faire entendre sa voix
la libye est un pays africain et une
réunion à alger autres pays africains
donc l'egypte qui en ce moment préside
l'union africaine ne lui en tout cas ce
pays n'est pas vraiment pour une
intervention de l'union
afrique est donc il ya en même temps
dans plusieurs pays africains qui se
battent pour faire entendre leur voix
légitime par l'intermédiaire du comité
de haut niveau comité dont qui présidé
par monsieur sassou n'guesso pour que
l'afrique fasse entendre sa voix il ne
peut pas avoir logiquement de résolution
du conflit en libye pays africains sans
les pays africains jusque-là l'onu a
manifestement échoué dans la résolution
du conflit libyen c'est ce constat qui
pousse aussi aujourd'hui l'union
africaine à s'investir davantage sur
cette question oui ils veulent
s'investir davantage mais à chaque
sommet où ils sont soit ostracisé mis de
côté mise à l'écart bon ça souligne
l'état des forces et le rapport de force
géopolitiques et géostratégiques on voit
bien que la libye est un pays où d'un
pays géostratégique où les convoitises
internationale qu'on voit donc 7,7 libye
et les trois camps entre guillemets en
tout cas les deux premiers le camp de sa
rage et le clan d'actares et l'on vous
voit bien que les décisions qui ont été
prises alger n'ont été respectées par
personne pas seulement par la turquie et
que les armes continuent à affluer donc
on voit bien que la résolution du
conflit ont achoppé alger à berlin et là
on va essayer donc à brazzaville donc
les pays africains vont essayer de faire
entendre leur voix et l'objectif de
cette réunion à brazzaville s'est
notamment de tenter de convaincre les
protagonistes du conflit d'accepter
l'idée d'un forum de réconciliation
alors un forum de réconciliation un
forum
l'épaisseur géopolitique géostratégique
de pacification de transition de
réorganisation étatiques pour une
solution rejetée
retrouvez donc qu'il n'ya plus cette
dislocation cette fragmentation du 2
de la libye donc l'union africaine va
jouer pleinement essaye de jouer
pleinement son rôle même si la tâche est
gigantesque et les puissances étrangères
ou autres n'en verront qu'on verra
comment elles vont réagir mais en tout
cas c'est un combat géopolitique pour
que l'union africaine 60 et ce forum de
réconciliation pourrait se tenir à addis
abeba au cours des six prochains mois
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre aussi à ce
que
le maréchal haftar et son rival libyen
fayez à âge se réunissent se retrouvent
et peut-être discutent et échangent
j'espère que ce sera génial ça rate et
monsieur haftar verront l'union
africaine comme un partenaire pivot très
important et déterminant dans la
résolution de leur conflit et que
l'union africaine addis abeba en
ethiopie donc ce siège de l'union
africaine soit le théâtre dieu d'une
résolution en état qui se retrouve très
concrètement tour autour du président
denis vous avez autour les présidents
célia mais vous avez aussi le prochain
président l'union africaine c'est une
présidence tournante dont quel président
ramaphosa président de l'afrique du sud
qui lui a bien dit et déclaré que le
conflit libyen va être en dos en haut de
la pile des problématiques à livrer donc
à une autre vision géopolitique interne
à l'afrique que celle qui lie à que
tient en ce moment le président de
l'egypte donc c'est la semaine prochaine
à le la passation de pouvoir on voit
bien une accélération diplomatique au
sein du continent africain donc à une
bonne partie des pays frontalier
l'algérie la tunisie le soudan le niger
et même un peu plus loin parce que la
crise du sahel même si c'est pas
seulement le seul le seul élément de
déclencheur de la crise du sahel mais la
libye et ce qui a été fait à l'encontre
de kadhafi a été l'erreur initiale de la
communauté internationale sans avoir
assez écoutés l'union africaine
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage jean
claude félix tchicaya je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur à l'ehess